while Netflix is good for an afternoon
of binge watching your favorite TV shows
it has a great movie selection - even
though the titles Netflix offers change
from time to time they consistently
offer up some really great movies from
older classics to more recent treasures
do yourself a favor and add to your
queue these hidden gems on Netflix
Kagemusha Akira Kurosawa's kg Musha
stands as one of the legendary directors
finest works amazingly Kurosawa could
not secure financing for the film in
Japan prompted Kurosawa fans George
Lucas and Francis Ford Coppola to get
20th Century Fox to produce it the
sweeping epic won the Palm D'Or at
Cannes and reignited Kurosawa's career
The Last Unicorn
yes The Last Unicorn is an animated
children's movie but don't lump this
haunting and beautiful tale with the
usual Disney fare for starters the
gorgeously unique animation style might
be familiar to some viewers as the core
members of this animation team would go
on to form Japan Studio Ghibli the tale
is brought to life by a stellar voice
cast that includes Christopher Lee Jeff
Bridges and Mia Farrow and the
enchanting score is provided by seventy
soft rockers America
the thin blue line long before making a
murderer
there was the thin blue line former
private detective Errol Morris directed
this chilling documentary with the
intention of bringing more attention to
the case of Randall Adams a man
sentenced to death for the murder of a
police officer
Morris's work paid off when his film and
the many discrepancies in the evidence
testimony had uncovered prompted
officials to reopen the case eventually
exonerating Adams and overturning his
conviction things we lost in the fire
Benicio del Toro plays Jerry a
struggling heroin addict trying to
reconnect with life and love he's joined
by Audrey played by Halle Berry who
faces her own uphill climb as a recently
widowed mother of two this drama avoids
the formulaic and focuses on the
poignant and with stunning performances
from both Barry and el Toro
it's a must-watch dope this
coming-of-age drama Dee put
self-described geek Malcolm shameik
Moore and his friends in a difficult
position when his application to Harvard
is jeopardized by a drug deal
Moore gives an outstanding performance
and Director Rick family WA pulls us
along a wild ride with a smart story
that's downright hilarious at times if I
got like one of those photogenic brains
give me photographic memory what I'll
just say I mean yeah you said it yeah
reiterating beasts of no nation Netflix
made its first major foray into original
films when it acquired beasts of no
nation directed by true detective vet
cary fukunaga it tells the harrowing
powerful tale of a West African child
caught in a civil war and recruited to a
rebel militia as a child soldier Idris
Elba gives a commanding and terrifying
performance is the militia leader who
orders his soldiers to perform ever more
horrific acts the fundamentals of caring
another winner from the Netflix table of
original films the fundamentals of
caring takes the road movie formula and
gives it an offbeat twist
ah
Paul Rudd and Craig Roberts team up as
respectively a caretaker and a teen
afflicted with muscular dystrophy out to
explore the country and themselves while
picking up a hitchhiking Selena Gomez
along the way writer director Robert
Burnett's deft touch with the material
makes for an enjoyable diverting journey
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know about your
favorite little-known Netflix gems
[Music]